[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
Welcome back.
In this episode, we're going
to do something special,
and that's write our own
classifier from scratch.
If you're new to
machine learning,
this is a big milestone.
Because if you can follow
along and do this on your own,
it means you understand an
important piece of the puzzle.
The classifier we're
going to write today
is a scrappy version
of k-Nearest Neighbors.
That's one of the simplest
classifiers around.
First, here's a quick outline of
what we'll do in this episode.
We'll start with our code
from Episode 4, Let's
Write a Pipeline.
Recall in that episode we
did a simple experiment.
We imported a data set and
split it into train and test.
We used train to
train a classifier,
and test to see how
accurate it was.
Writing the
classifier is the part
we're going to focus on today.
Previously we imported
the classifier
from a library using
these two lines.
Here we'll comment them
out and write our own.
The rest of the pipeline
will stay exactly the same.
I'll pop in and out of the
screencast to explain things
as we go along.
To start, let's run our
pipeline to remind ourselves
what the accuracy was.
As you can see, it's over 90%.
And that's the goal
for the classifier
we'll write ourselves.
Now let's comment
out that import.
Right off the bat,
this breaks our code.
So the first thing we need
to do is fix our pipeline.
And to do that, we'll implement
a class for our classifier.
I'll call it ScrappyKNN.
And by scrappy, I
mean bare bones.
Just enough to get it working.
Next, I'll change our
pipeline to use it.
Now let's see what methods
we need to implement.
Looking at the interface
for a classifier,
we see there are two
we care about-- fit,
which does the
training, and predict,
which does the prediction.
First we'll declare
our fit method.
Remember this takes the features
and labels for the training set
as input, so we'll add
parameters for those.
Now let's move on to
our predict method.
As input, this receives the
features for our testing data.
And as output, it returns
predictions for the labels.
Our first goal is to get
the pipeline working,
and to understand
what these methods do.
So before we write
our real classifier,
we'll start with
something simpler.
We'll write a random classifier.
And by random, I mean
we'll just guess the label.
To start, we'll add some code
to the fit and predict methods.
In fit, I'll store the
training data in this class.
You can think of this
as just memorizing it.
And you'll see why
we do that later on.
Inside the predict
method, remember
that we'll need to return
a list of predictions.
That's because the parameter,
X_test, is actually
a 2D array, or list of lists.
Each row contains the features
for one testing example.
To make a prediction
for each row,
I'll just randomly pick a
label from the training data
and append that to
our predictions.
At this point, our
pipeline is working again.
So let's run it and
see how well it does.
Recall there are three
different types of flowers
in the iris dataset, so
accuracy should be about 33%.
Now we know the interface
for a classifier.
But when we started
this exercise,
our accuracy was above 90%.
So let's see if
we can do better.
To do that, we'll
implement our classifier,
which is based on
k-Nearest Neighbors.
Here's the intuition for
how that algorithm works.
Let's return to our drawings
of green dots and red dots
from the last episode.
Imagine the dots we
see on the screen
are the training data we
memorized in the fit method,
say for a toy dataset.
Now imagine we're asked to make
a prediction for this testing
point that I'll
draw here in gray.
How can we do that?
Well in a nearest
neighbor classifier,
it works exactly like it sounds.
We'll find the
training point that's
closest to the testing point.
This point is the
nearest neighbor.
Then we'll predict
that the testing
point has the same label.
For example, we'll guess that
this testing dot is green,
because that's the color
of its nearest neighbor.
As another example, if we
had a testing dot over here,
we'd guess that it's red.
Now what about this one
right in the middle?
Imagine that this dot is
equidistant to the nearest
green dot and the
nearest red one.
There's a tie, so how
could we classify it?
Well one way is we could
randomly break the tie.
But there's another way,
and that's where k comes in.
K is the number of
neighbors we consider
when making our prediction.
If k was 1, we'd just look at
the closest training point.
But if k was 3, we'd look
at the three closest.
In this case, two of those
are green and one is red.
To predict, we could vote and
predict the majority class.
Now there's more detail
to this algorithm,
but that's enough
to get us started.
To code this up,
first we'll need a way
to find the nearest neighbor.
And to do that, we'll
measure the straight line
distance between two points,
just like you do with a ruler.
There's a formula for that
called the Euclidean Distance,
and here's what the
formula looks like.
It measures the distance
between two points,
and it works a bit like
the Pythagorean Theorem.
A squared plus B squared
equals C squared.
You can think of this term
as A, or the difference
between the first two features.
Likewise, you can think
of this term as B,
or the difference between
the second pair of features.
And the distance we compute is
the length of the hypotenuse.
Now here's something cool.
Right now we're
computing distance
in two-dimensional space,
because we have just two
features in our toy dataset.
But what if we had three
features or three dimensions?
Well then we'd be in a cube.
We can still visualize
how to measure distance
in the space with a ruler.
But what if we had four
features or four dimensions,
like we do in iris?
Well, now we're in
a hypercube, and we
can't visualize this very easy.
The good news is the
Euclidean Distance
works the same way regardless
of the number of dimensions.
With more features, we can just
add more terms to the equation.
You can find more details
about this online.
Now let's code up
Euclidean distance.
There are plenty
of ways to do that,
but we'll use a library
called scipy that's
already installed by Anaconda.
Here, A and B are lists
of numeric features.
Say A is a point from
our training data,
and B is a point from
our testing data.
This function returns the
distance between them.
That's all the math
we need, so now
let's take a look at the
algorithm for a classifier.
To make a prediction
for a test point,
we'll calculate the distance
to all the training points.
Then we'll predict the testing
point has the same label
as the closest one.
I'll delete the random
prediction we made,
and replace it with a method
that finds the closest training
point to the test point.
For this video hard,
I'll hard-code k to 1,
so we're writing a nearest
neighbor classifier.
The k variable won't
appear in our code,
since we'll always just
find the closest point.
Inside this method, we'll loop
over all the training points
and keep track of the
closest one so far.
Remember that we memorized
the training data in our fit
function, and X_train
contains the features.
To start, I'll calculate the
distance from the test point
to the first training point.
I'll use this variable to
keep track of the shortest
distance we've found so far.
And I'll use this
variable to keep
track of the index of the
training point that's closest.
We'll need this later
to retrieve its label.
Now we'll iterate over all
the other training points.
And every time we
find a closer one,
we'll update our variables.
Finally, we'll use
the index to return
the label for the
closest training example.
At this point, we have a working
nearest neighbor classifier,
so let's run it and see
what the accuracy is.
As you can see, it's over 90%.
And we did it.
When you run this on
your own, the accuracy
might be a bit different because
of randomness in the train test
split.
Now if you can code this
up and understand it,
that's a big
accomplishment because it
means you can write a simple
classifier from scratch.
Now, there are a
number of pros and cons
to this algorithm, many of
which you can find online.
The basic pro is that it's
relatively easy to understand,
and works reasonably
well for some problems.
And the basic cons
are that it's slow,
because it has to iterate
over every training point
to make a prediction.
And importantly, as
we saw in Episode 3,
some features are more
informative than others.
But there's not an
easy way to represent
that in k-Nearest Neighbors.
In the long run, we
want a classifier
that learns more complex
relationships between features
and the label we're
trying to predict.
A decision tree is a
good example of that.
And a neural network like we
saw in TensorFlow Playground
is even better.
OK, hope that was helpful.
Thanks as always for watching.
You can follow me on Twitter
for updates and, of course,
Google Developers.
And I'll see you guys next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]